first off though i know it was
thanksgiving yesterday so i got some
brooks kefka cupcakes for everyone in
the crowd
and if brooks wants the last one he can
have it but anyone wants to have it you
guys pass it around take one come on my
man good luck today man let's have some
fun all right cupcake olive branch
filled
it's cute
but
nicely done nice one thank you so got
the free drop ends up with a four a
couple of fours to get us started here
remember a 12 hole match
take the water out of play
yeah we'll find out
very nice that's a statement right there
you could see that there was some
darkness look at the darkness of the
grain there that's going to kick it to
his right that's where the grain's going
first you can see it moving to his right
and then straightens up
phil good call bud
one up through two
yeah there's a little three
and that's right on it
it's got action here
[Music]
he is one of the best
at this range especially on a firm fast
tricky greens like in the majors that's
why he does so well in the majors he is
so solid on these that this one should
go right in the center
it does
so
up and down for three it wasn't good
[Music]
hello
what do you do when you're in a bush
like that
well find a sprinkler
if people can see me or not
i have no problem i have no problem
moving my ball off the guys can't see me
yeah you ain't seen you ain't trying
chuck that's it brother
not an easy shot but doable
keeps
i cutting know
all right not that bad i can see it just
covered it's good spot absolutely it's
all it's just a bunker yeah no it's just
on the middle yeah this to have the hole
and it draws perfectly so it's
right down the center he's gonna have
even shorter than i said oh look out
coming right into your living room oh
i mean that is so attractive
his second now
i miss hit it but the tough thing out of
that first cause it's still it's got
enough height to catch the front
that's bouncing it's literally going to
be middle of the green it's actually
going to be really good
wow
safety
yeah good job
nice very nice
get left
all right whoa
all right there's to go three up
oh
brooks kepka pours it in wow
any questions and he can play it a
little long right of the pin and have it
come right back to the hole too
come on do your thing
ah it didn't roll up yeah it did yeah
see all right
i think it needs to sit i'm not sure
oh wow sit where sit it dead right next
to the park
[Applause]
come on spin
okay i'm so surprised yeah
yeah i get pop cash thank you
all right
it's a runaway train
he did say it wasn't going to go 12.
he did say that
so how are you feeling about your
prediction right now
there you go
where is this on the pga tour man i mean
he plays so
so good right now man this is kind of
like my major right now right
i guess it is
ah it's got that
stop spinning
shoot
it did not bank right
brooks good job man
enjoy yeah awesome appreciate it moment
of truth conceded
that's it
wins
at least a little bit happy with the
respect that seemed to be earned today
yeah i hope so i mean look i'm just
going to be playing my game no matter
what and i've always had a respect for
brooks because his four major
championships and what he's done for the
game and
at the end of the day it was 12 holes
and he uh he got me so hopefully they'll
be a rematch sometime soon obviously
watching him uh up close and personal
it's pretty neat pretty special to watch
him hit the ball like i said there's
there is respect there but at the same
time it was fun to come out here and
settle this and um
enough said wait did we just become best
[Laughter]
the next one friends